we're now ready to solve for
we're now ready to solve for a b and c
given these three equations with three
unknowns so let's first start with these
top two constraints so i have this one
right over here in blue let me just copy
and paste it right over here and then
let me rewrite this constraint but let
me multiply it by negative two so that i
can cancel out the c terms so it's
negative two a
minus two b
minus two c is equal to negative 2
and then
if i
if i perform if i add the left-hand
sides and the right-hand sides on the
left-hand sides i get 6a
plus
2b
these cancel out is equal to 3 and on
the right hand or and then the other
constraint i could use is this orange
one and the green to get the c's to
cancel out here so i have 27a
plus 9b
plus 3c
is equal to
is equal to 14.
and here let's see i can multiply by
negative 3 if i want to get the c's to
cancel out again and my whole goal is to
have two equations and two unknowns that
have leveraged that have leveraged these
two constraints in tandem and these two
constraints in tandem so now i'm going
to do these two so i multiply this
equation times negative three i get
negative three a
minus 3b
minus 3c is equal to negative 3
and now i can perform the subtraction
and i get 24 a
plus 6b
these cancel is equal to 11. now i have
two equations in two unknowns and let's
see if i multiply this equation right
over here times
negative three i should get the b's to
cancel out so let's do that
so if i multiply this times negative 3
this constraint or or this term 6a times
negative 3 is negative 18 a
2b times negative 3 minus 6b
is equal to 3 times negative 3 is equal
to negative 9
and now if we add
both sides
on the left-hand side
on the left-hand side we have let's see
24 a minus 18 a is 6
a these cancel is equal to 11
minus 9 is 2 divide both sides by 6 we
get a is equal to 2 over 6 which is the
same thing as
1 over 3. and so now we can substitute
back to solve for b
so let's see we have 6
6 times
1 3 our a is 1 3
plus 2 b
is equal to three
six times one third is two two plus two
b
is equal to three subtract two from both
sides
two b is equal to one
divide both sides by two b is equal to
one-half so a is one-third b is one-half
now we just have to solve for c
so we can go back to this original
equation right over here so we have
one-third
plus one half
plus c is equal to one actually let me
do that over here so i have some space
so i have some space let me do it right
over here
so i have one third
plus one half plus c is equal to 1. let
me find ourselves a common denominator
so let's see a common multiple of 3 2
and i guess you could say 1 this is 1
over 1 is going to be 6. so i can
rewrite this as 2 6
plus 3 6
plus c is equal to 6 over 6
1 is the same thing as 6 6.
so this is 5 6
plus c is equal to 6
6. subtract 5 6 from both sides we get c
is equal to 1 6.
so c
is equal to 1 6. and there we are we
deserve a drum roll now we've figured
out a formula we have figured out a
formula for the sum of the first n
squares
so we can rewrite this this this formula
is now going to be a is one-third so
it's one-third
n to the third power plus one-half
plus one-half
n squared
let me make sure you don't look like
doesn't look like that n is it one half
n squared
plus
one over
six
n
so it's a pretty pretty handy this is a
pretty
this right over here is a pretty handy
formula if now you wanted to find
0 squared plus 1 squared plus 2 squared
plus 3 squared all the way to 100
squared instead of having to add up
squaring 100 numbers and then adding
them together you could figure out one
third of a hundred to the third power
plus one half times 100 squared plus
one-sixth times a hundred or you could
do that for any number so this is kind
of a this right over here is a there's a
pretty neat little formula